hey everyone tickets are now on sale for
marvel studios black widow we have to go
back to where it all started
[Music]
grab your tickets today or else or else
what
where else you know
david what no we're not doing that what
you know it's a gesture for
or else you won't have tickets that's no
david yeah that's not that's what that
gesture means no but
two run action
black widow is something that the marvel
universe has
never experienced before the action in
this film
is real these huge armored vehicles
going through
these iconic streets in budapest
budapest itself is so important to whom
natasha really is
and what drives her and she finds this
family from her past there
so we're going to talk like grown-ups is
that what we are
within like two days of knowing scarlet
i was just ramming her into a door frame
all the fighting in this film is so
emotional and
about not knowing how to say what you
feel
[Music]
it's good to see you too sis they're
some of the most
intense fights that we've had in the mcu
there's this big fight scene in this
enormous prison there were 400
extras feel like a movie it feels real
i wanted to create something really
visceral
and fun but to talk about natasha as a
human being
to let audiences see a sign of her that
they had never seen before
i've spent a decade of time with this
character
[Music]
and she's finally able to write her own
story
[Music]
i'm done running for my past
welcome back everyone this is going to
be my new black widow trailer video
there's obviously a ton of new footage
marvel was not joking when i was talking
about them releasing the entire movie in
little short two-minute clips
but we only have a couple weeks to go
we're doing a giveaway for disney plus
memberships and i'll do a giveaway for
movie tickets too
if you wind up winning you can pick
either one that you want all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
all your theories
about what happens with the new version
of black widow after the black widow
movie
so the big thing with this new footage
is that there's a whole bunch of stuff
going on here a bunch of really cool
fight scenes just showing you how crazy
things get but there are a couple
specific scenes in here that reveal
who taskmaster is that you probably
spotted and we basically have what
amounts to the opening scene of the
movie with black widow going to budapest
but i'll start with the taskmaster stuff
first just because there's still so many
crazy theories about what's going on
with taskmaster but i do feel like this
footage and some of these scenes in here
completely answer this so in the new
footage there's a much better example of
who taskmaster is
when he's in the middle of this big
fight with red guardian in this facility
wherever they're experimenting on the
black widows is the same place where you
see taskmaster watching back
all the avengers footage copying their
moves he starts brawling with red
guardian shows off his avengers moves
like we've seen the black panther moves
with the vibranium claws he pulls a
spiderman backflip kick
a captain america shield stomp then in
the new footage he shows he's got a
retractable blade in his gauntlet that's
not meant to be a wolverine move or
anything like that we don't have
wolverine in the mcu
at least yet and none of the classic
avengers characters use wrist blades
that are that big so you can pick your
reference as to which avenger you think
he copied that move from but when he's
about ready to spear red guardian with
the blade molina
vostikov rachel weiss's character blocks
him and does her own version of that
signature black widow
spinning leg takedown move it's the same
move that black widow used on winter
soldier
it's one of her go-to classics and since
molina was kind of a mother too
natasha black widow when she was growing
up i think they're trying to imply that
she learned some of her moves from
molina as a child
but as you probably guess where i'm
going with this the obvious thing here
is that molina
is literally fighting taskmaster a
completely separate character
in this scene so hopefully that'll take
everybody off the rachel vice taskmaster
theories
but for example here when they're
getting ready to brawl red guardian and
taskmaster the person in the costume
is about as tall as david harper and
look how tall david harbor is compared
to scarlett johansson i mean she's
already tiny in real life so it looks
like an even bigger difference
but think about which other characters
standing here on stage next to david
harbor at comic-con are about as tall as
he is
so i just think it's more evidence
confirming that it's really the mason
character played by ot bentley
and he's playing dual roles in the movie
we already know that for some of the
movie he's playing a character called
mason the character the black widow gets
all of her gear
her weapons from anything that she needs
when she goes on missions
it's implied that they have some sort of
sexual relationship in the past or in
the present
and i think the idea with the big
taskmaster twist as i've said before
is that it's going to be this big
betrayal when it's revealed who's inside
the mask like oh the person you trusted
this whole time you were in this
relationship with
was secretly pulling the strings behind
the black widow program this whole time
the very thing that you've been trying
to take down the whole thing with rachel
vice's character though because her name
is bolina vostakov and she is the iron
maiden character in the comics
a black widow villain a lot of people
were still kind of expecting her to be
connected to taskmaster somehow in the
red room
when she did her big interview about the
movie she said that since natasha had
defected to the united states started
working for nick fury been part of the
avengers
all these years she'd been living on
this farm raising pigs experimenting on
them
so early theory some of the research
that she's been doing as a scientist has
been actually helping
taskmaster and drakov brainwash the
other black widows so maybe unwittingly
she's been helping the new black widow
program and for instance here too when
they're in this giant big action scene
you see some other
armored people that look similar to
taskmaster's armor but this isn't
taskmaster this is just another person
with armor that's like taskmaster
so it sounds like they're trying to
create more task masters
so to speak like create more characters
that can do what he does and replicate
his abilities
this sort of goes hand in hand with the
idea of the super soldier program
everybody wants their super soldiers in
these different countries
i also love the footage in here of david
harper's red guardian character going
full hulk
in that giant prison yard fight in
siberia you get a much better sense of
his super soldier powers
so if you're not familiar with a red
guardian character in the comics he's
basically the russian version of captain
america
developed by the soviet government
separate from hydra's winter soldier
program
they're like a whole separate group
doing things in siberia on their own
they're not connected to the russian
government although they do have members
infiltrating the russian government they
kind of addressed this during falcon and
winter soldier when nagel is talking
about his history developing his new
version of the super soldier serum in
the weapons plus program how he kind of
bounced around to different places
different people hired him like hydra
hired him for a little while
in the comics at least the black widows
when they graduate from the red room in
addition to sterilizing them so they're
not capable of getting pregnant
they would also give the new black
widows a form of the super soldier serum
now it was a deluded form so it wasn't
like the full dose that captain america
got but that's why in the comics black
widow this tiny little person is able to
run around with the other a-list
avengers with legit super powers
and hold her own they never really
addressed the idea that maybe natasha
got a form of the super soldier serum
when she went through the program but
because this is the black widow movie
this would be the place to
explain that whether she did or she did
not the way they've been playing the
character for the last 10 years or so
since iron man 2 seems like she does not
have the super soldier serum it just
feels like all of her attacks would land
way harder if she had super soldier
serum in her body
but then they have that big opening
scene where the new squad of black
widows and taskmaster come to get
natasha and yelena bulova
yellen apparently has set a bunch of
booby traps around her apartment in
budapest
what happens in budapest stays in
budapest i am sure there will be plenty
of budapest jokes
it just seems like she's rigged the
circuit from all the light switches to
blow when she turns it on
that's also probably her just taking
advantage of really shoddy super old
wiring like no joke a long time ago i
lived in this really crappy new york
city apartment that was the size of a
broom closet
and it was a miracle that i didn't get
electrocuted every day
just turning the light switches on and
apparently in this scene one of the
black widows would rather kill natasha
than apparently be saved by her like she
tries to save her and the other one just
eats out 40 or 50 feet below to the
ground
they just want to show you how hardcore
the new black widow program has become
in the extreme tactics that the new
widows use to take out their targets
like completely ignoring their own lives
in pursuit of a target
yelena bulova has that narration in the
other trailers where she explains that
taskmaster and drakov
are essentially brainwashing the new
recruits even more than what was done to
natasha and her when they came up
through the red room
but this will overlap with the loki
episodes and then we also have rick and
morty episodes rick and morty season
five is starting next week so i'll be
doing videos for that too every week
ten episodes in season five but we
finally actually have some marvel movies
that we can go see
or you could stay home and watch them on
disney plus pretty much either way you
want to go
but if you have any questions about
what's going on with the movie or what's
going on with loki or anything else in
the mcu just let me know in the comments
if there's any special bonus videos that
you want me to do
everyone click here for my full loki
episode 1 video
and click here for that brand new loki
avengers secret wars teaser
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you